[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
June 2nd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
among the items that parents passed down
to their children is the family home but
that often comes with emotional and
financial questions Wall Street Journal
personal finance reporter Veronica
dagger joins us to discuss so Veronica
why do parents often choose to leave the
family home to their children and how
common is it well it's a common way to
transfer wealth there's no recent data
that tracks home inheritance nationally
but we hear from Realtors we hear from
advisors that people continue to do this
it's a nice way to leave a legacy
financially to your family and you're
hoping also maybe the people hold on to
the house that's often not the case
though more than three-quarters of
parents plan to leave a home to their
children when they die and that's
according to a 2023 Charles Schwab
survey but on the flip side children are
often reluctant to sell but finances and
simplicity of unloading the property
often went out so nearly 70 percent of
those who expect to inherit a home from
their parents plan to sell it and that's
according to the survey as well so
people want to get rid of the house yeah
leaving the house to the kids is one
thing but do the kids actually want to
take on ownership of a family home it
sounds like there should be a
conversation or two about the house as
part of an inheritance what kind of
financial question should be on the list
you've got to think about if you're the
inheritor can you afford this house
we're dealing with Rising costs of
renovation property taxes are higher in
many areas of the country utilities are
more expensive not to mention there's no
official stats on this but in general
what I hear from advisors is that people
tend to inherit the home when they're in
their 50s or 60s sometimes a little
earlier but by that point many
inheritors already have their home
they're already established in a state
perhaps a different state than where
their parents have the home and so this
would be an additional cost and these
are people who don't need another home
to take care of and so it's not so
attractive to people even though it is a
tight real estate market these people
already have homes so they don't
necessarily need it if you have
school-aged kids you don't want to have
to uproot your kids and move across the
country just so you can say oh yeah I
took on my parents home so the high
prices of homes have also made it very
motivating for heirs to sell if you can
get top dollar for your parents home
that is in a hot location why wouldn't
you sell it and then financially you
know if the parents have owned the home
for decades then the mortgage could be
already paid off and that would ease the
financial burden on siblings if they
wanted to keep it in the family
absolutely however there's still the
financial upkeep of that right even
though the mortgage is paid you still
have to pay those property taxes those
aren't going away and you still have to
deal with all the other costs again if
you're in a different state you have to
deal with security if you're say you're
going to be renting this out to another
family you have to make sure they're
going to pay their bills going to
maintain the property properly if the
house is going to sit empty who's going
to watch it how are you going to make
sure squatters don't come around I mean
we've heard those kind of crazy stories
so there's a lot of considerations to
think about in general a lot of the
errors we speak to are saying you know
what I appreciate the gift from Mom and
Dad but I'd rather take this house sell
it than use the proceeds to do something
like fund my own retirement and or my
travel goals or my kids college
education like there's so many other
things that I want and I can do with
this money that I would receive from the
proceeds of this house it just makes
more sense for me to step away and sell
it and when you think about it from a
generational standpoint let's say the
parents bought the house in the 60s or
the 70s tastes and Styles have changed
completely so a lot of the older
generation and I mean people maybe in
their 70s or 80s in general I'm hearing
from advisors have been a bit more
conservative with their money they may
have not updated the house or may they
just have different tastes that they
might like wood and traditional
materials in the house whereas some
younger folks might want a more modern
look kind of that Farmhouse Chic that
their parents may not have and so if you
think about the different styles of the
house to update a house to your own
taste that costs a good deal of money so
the interest of Errors to do that is
also very low why not not just buy a
newer house that might be easier to
maintain also might be cheaper to ensure
what we're seeing in certain areas of
the country like the coasts places like
Charleston some areas of Florida even
California some insurers are pulling out
they are making it very difficult for
people to get home insurance not to
mention flood insurance and if they do
you're going to have to pay top dollar
in order to get that insurance so if you
don't have insurance that's all the more
reason to get rid of a house because
it's just so risky all right so let's
say ownership has transferred to the
siblings and they want to keep the house
but one sibling wants to buy the others
out what should they keep in mind
regarding that process you want to make
sure you're going to use a reasonable
evaluation method for the house so
everyone's going to agree on the price
you're going to ask for it and if you're
buying out your siblings are they okay
with that price don't expect to be able
to get an under the market price from
your siblings because at the end of the
day they want that money they want to
get the top dollar for that house most
likely and so if you want to avoid hard
feelings you need to think about a fair
price for that house and you can use the
value reported on the estate tax return
if it's recent or you might want to
obtain a few appraisals use an average
also you need to make sure that you're
not getting in over your head
financially because mortgage rates as we
know they're hovering around seven
percent right now and so if you're
making a decision to buy out your
siblings just because you want to be the
ones that carry on the family tradition
but that's going to bury you financially
it's going to put you in a lot of stress
and mess up your future financial goals
it's just making a financial decision
based on emotions or to please what you
think your mom and dad would want you to
do or carry on some Legacy that isn't
good for your finances could really
backfire on you that's Wall Street
Journal personal finance reporter
Veronica dagger and that's it for your
money briefing this week our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris zinsley I'm
your host Jay Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]